and then you know you come here at the
manny well i met you at the manny
pacquiao yeah right right and i go who's
that little whimsical [ __ ] that fairy
yeah and kalila go oh he's great his
name is gilbert can you help us we got
you in
we got you a little following here
through the tiger belly
um i try to give you a mad tv audition
you went into that yeah that was fun um
you make a little bit money on this
podcast do you not yeah right you don't
have a day job really
or anything no yeah yeah
um can i get a hawaiian cookie
i got you a hawaiian no no you don't go
to hawaii
show up at my house
with empty-handed
no you're right i made a mistake it's
not just a mistake it's you know there's
no consequences to you because you're
entitled you're not going to
feel any effects of any kind of
consequence as it is i feel like because
you're above it no you don't feel so sad
yeah i'm so sad that's not sadness all
right and
that's not that all right i'm so sad all
right whatever yeah okay i'm just
letting you know it hurts
but it burns can i help that
can i help it burns in my butthole for
some reason and my heart
yeah can i help
60 bottle forty percent hard okay well
can i make it less burn
i'm gonna go
no the only way you can make it up to me
the only way you can
is the next time you go out of the
country or to a different an exotic land
yeah you gotta bring me back something
substantial
okay not cookies this time though
it's gotta be like oh no the [ __ ]
one of the hawaiian kings carve this out
of a limestone i gotta find a [ __ ]
polynesian thing yeah yeah you couldn't
even get him one of those like 99 cent
chocolates with a macadamia he doesn't
deserve that i got him the hawaiian
cookies no but whatever the hawaiian
cookie company the the tan the green
tins is it the hawaiian cookie company
yeah
ala moana mall right yeah what i want
also is i've always wanted one of those
who love dashboard that figure
for the car yeah i don't even know if
they sell those in hawaii they do [ __ ]
face i think they sell them here babe
they sell them here as well but i want
hawaiian one okay from hawaii from
hawaii but i have a better gif what is
that we talked about it before this what
is it and i'm gonna do this i'm gonna
say it on air see it if i ever get
nominated for a bafta
or an emmy i don't want bafta okay fine
emmy it's gotta be happening what about
teen choice awards i feel like that's
more doable for me no no no no no look
let's be honest i'm probably gonna get a
chance if it's not the emmys
then nothing
okay or oscar obviously
you're never gonna win an oscar hey you
never know okay you might
but you might it doesn't matter anything
above emmy yeah the first name i have to
say i can't say thank you i can't say
god i can't all right so let's let's
replay this okay right so
for best supporting actor for the movie
um gooks are us
this comedy i don't know stephen yoon
brian t
sung kang
creek gilbert cologne
right ken jung let's suppose winner and
the winner is
gilbert
[Music]
this is for giveaways first
oscar right so everyone applause okay go
bobby
bobby lee
if you're asian out there
you think you're here because of
yourself
do you think you're here because of your
talent yeah
sure there was margaret show she's great
yeah cut that out who was cutter out of
it okay yeah yeah sure there was that
american girl show yeah yeah do that
all of you look at yourself yes now look
at me look what i'm holding yes who's
the first asian american
on network
tv
not me but
it wasn't me say it we weren't alive
bobby lee yeah yeah yeah there we go
thank god to my parents and kalala and
george love you all no day under
if you say george
he's going to die i'll kill him what if
i say shout out to king failure
yeah
nothing what nothing
king failure white nothing there's no
need for this brand yeah i don't i don't
like i'm going to say something very
[ __ ] can i just say something about
this guy george why
he you know he has notebooks right he
has like notes he has all these things
he's a producer right don't say anything
until i finish okay do you promise back
up george back up
so we so he sets up this like production
meeting to pitch to a production company
right
i don't know anything about it
i wake up and claudia goes wake up you
have to go to this pitch meeting at a
company i go what
i don't want to go
you told george you would go